So I'm going to start off with just a,
uh,
a small background here
at my pace as a series.
I didn't envision myself doing
this so much, but it became so,
and every time I'd do another book
at adds meaning at least to my life.
And it began when I took on the
Sheryl Sandberg Lean in conversation.
I wanted to expand it to be more about
the range of choices we make in our life.
Some people that I say are leaning in
going on the autobon full speed ahead.
Others have a more winding path.
And my objective was that we celebrate
all our choices and then we reserve
judgment.
And that was this book right here.
And so the cover is about
blue sky and open roads.
That's how we should see our world.
Blue sky and open roads.
And then I thought it was done.
And then the next thing that happened
was that my mother was Aylien.
She was coming on to the end of her
life and I wanted to elevate the
conversation from focusing on
her to something more meaningful.
So I asked people the question,
what's one lesson you take from your
mother and how it's impacted your life?
And that gave us a really
rich conversation. And I found
out by the way, that, uh,
mothers and their kids have way more
complex relationships than I probably
realized at the time.
And that was booked two.
And this was about showing your
gratitude or, uh, as I say,
giving either a flower or an olive branch
as you find comfort and peace in your
relationship with your mom. So now I had
two books and the marketer in me said,
well, now you probably need to start
thinking about a tagline. Um, and,
but I wasn't. So, and
I thought about that.
And so what the at my pace
series is about is at its heart,
it's about personal stories.
And then from there we were
able to have a conversation,
an expanded conversation. And from there,
hopefully there's emerging insights. Uh,
so it's stories, conversation, insights.
Now I feel like I'm having
a tagline start to happen.
And then after that, uh, I was not
quite sure what I wanted to do,
but I realized that I have a
lot of millennials in my life.
I have three children and a son in law.
So I think technically I have for
millennials in my life and on good days,
I understand them on other days.
I'm sort of perplexed by the
way they frame their world.
But I don't fall prey to the
generalizations that we always hear about
millennials. You know, these are, these
are some of the ones, uh, you know,
my social media obsessed, narcissistic,
want to get there fast, you know,
you can imagine all the
ones that you've heard.
And I wanted to hear from them themselves,
how they look at their world,
what their challenges are and what we
as as baby boomers can glean from it and
also what they can share among themselves
that will help them as they find their
way. So just in terms of
the, at my pace format,
what happens is there are
there a thousand word pieces,
roughly their story oriented.
I give guidelines and I
helped contributors get their
pieces together as much or
as as they need. Uh, and um,
so I came up with some guidelines for
the thousand for the, for this one, Lisa,
who's right here was fortunate.
Shoot my first contributor.
She was an awesome one. Uh, there's 29.
And so what I wanted to do today is talk
about what I learned and what you do
with it. And I'm hoping that we
can have a conversation about this.
I would like this to be informal and I
would like you guys to ask questions or
give me your thoughts as you hear them.
So I'm going to start off by just
giving you some of the titles.
There's 29 pieces in here.
I'm going to give you some of the titles
to give you a feeling for what I heard.
And I want to see whether raise your hand,
if any of these either
resonate with you or you know,
somebody close in your life who you
think they could have meaningful. Okay.
So these are some of the
titles, uh, a layered identity
when the world tells,
you know,
detours.
Yeah.
Imposter Syndrome.
Okay.
Finding the power of me.
A series of new beginnings.
Okay.
A clash of perception and reality.
How to love myself,
the start and the restart,
turning,
caring into doing
and keeping the faith.
So those are just some,
um,
and what was exceptional to me about
these contributors as it was a look at
their lives and the most uncurated
way, they were extremely honest. They,
uh, when you read this book, you will
see that there's a fair bit of anxiety,
some depression, some stress,
tremendous uncertainty, self doubt,
all the things that we, you know,
I know as a, as a baby boomer,
I have felt for years,
but our twentysomethings feel that and um,
and they explain where it comes from and,
and what they're doing with it.
Okay. So, uh, I think the way, the, the,
the best way for me to begin
as to describe the first
piece in the book and the
last piece in the book, because I think
it really frames the discussion. Will,
the first piece is purposeful prisons.
A leasee wrote that and I,
well,
one of the questions I asked these
contributors is, what is a book,
a poem, a song, some new,
something that resonates with you.
I wanted a quick insight into
the window of their soul. Uh,
so tell me what that would be. Um,
and they could or could not use it.
It didn't matter to me, but at least it
helped me to understand who they were.
And so we see right away
said, oh, William Wordsworth,
nuns fret not now. I was an English major.
I happened to like worse, worse, worse.
But I did not recognize that poem.
Um,
and it's a wonderful poem
and in nuns front, not,
it's really about how the
constraints in our life,
sometimes us purpose and meaning.
And so Wordsworth discusses how nuns
like convents help poets like Sinus,
they're 14 lines.
And how,
while some people might find
those boundaries constraining,
infringing upon the things you want to do,
Wardsworth argues that those
boundaries are purposeful.
They're purposeful prisons that,
that anchor you and lacy who describes
being a software engineer at Ballet
Dancer and an observant Jew has
plenty of boundaries in her life.
But for Lacey, those boundaries
are purposeful. So she
makes the case for that,
those anchors, those very strong
anchors being a good thing in her life.
The last piece in the book is called color
outside the lines by Kimberly Roatan.
She is the oldest of the contributors.
She went to UC University of
Chicago. Law School, did really well,
had her pick of jobs at law
firms when she graduated.
Uh, deeply cares about the
social issues of our day,
wants her life to be dedicated
to the social issues of the day.
And so she picked what
she thought was the most,
one of the most progressive left leaning
law firms that she could find that she
could work in. Um, but it didn't last
very long for her. Even that did not work.
And so she leaves the law firm and she
goes and she fights for the social issues,
which include immigration rights, sex
worker rights, healthcare advocacy.
And she finds her way to today she is the
assistant director at northeastern law
school for policy. Uh, but
in the course of all that,
she discovered that she loves to paint.
She loved to dance. She, she came out,
there's a whole sort of sharing of her
life and a sharing of who she wants to
be, who she is. And so the,
there aren't too many boundaries for her.
For her,
it's about expressing yourself
and being true to who you are.
And so we have on one side,
purposeful prisons on another side,
color outside the lines,
which she literally as she paints with
her fingers and figuratively as she makes
choices in her life that defy some
of the more traditional choices. Um,
so we had that on the other end.
And so the question is, you know,
for these contributors,
for these 29,
where do I fit in and
what are my challenges?
And finding that place
where I can find a piece,
a truth to who I am, um, support
for the things I believe in.
I think that's the challenge. By the way,
I also was able to survey this group,
which is,
this is the first of the books that I
surveyed my contributors in the previous
one that just took their
stories and went from there.
But I wanted a little bit
of data because after all,
we live in a world of data and that's what
I do in my day job anyway. Uh, so, um, I,
I, I ended up, I read through these
stories working in the stories and I,
as I stepped back and look at them,
I found that they're basically
sort of five parts of,
of I what I think the contributor has
had to sort of conquer and manage to get
to a place that they felt good about.
Okay.
So the first one is just
about being healthy.
It's about being emotionally healthy.
It's about being physically healthy.
It's about feeling like you're standing
firm on your own two feet with energy
and purpose and ready to go.
That actually doesn't sound that hard,
but it's obviously it's very hard. And
uh, one of the early pieces I worked on,
uh,
was um,
a woman named Pam Nofx and she
writes a piece called heal thyself.
And what happened was I met her
sister and her sister said to me,
you need to get, you need to get ahold
of my sister. She has a piece in her.
It'd be very helpful, very therapeutic.
I think you should talk to her.
So I did talk to her and I'm just going
to read you the beginning of her piece
healed myself. Uh, she's 28,
so she's older and in this
range of 20 somethings,
I found that the older
you were in your 20s,
the more you had to share or more
willing you were to share what you had to
offer.
So this is what Pam says.
In June of 2017,
I was a bridesmaid for
the fifth time in my life,
I bought another expensive dress,
got my hair and makeup done and smiled
as I walked down the aisle on the
happiest day of someone else's life.
I looked around the room with this group
of friends and realize how far we had
come since high school,
six or the group of 10 were married
with one more couple on the way in a few
months. One couple was expecting a
child, another had moved to Sanford,
Connecticut and gotten a dog.
Most everyone was becoming
established in their careers.
These people were dear friends
and we shared a common history.
But in that moment I couldn't help but
feel pretty far from their realities.
So what happens to Pam is she
continues to do her her life,
but she, um, she looks at herself all
the time and feels like she's not,
she's not attractive.
She wants to eat less.
She ends up having some kind of an
eating disorder. Her Ma, she cries,
her mother says to her, we have to get
you help. This is not, uh, this is,
this is not okay.
And Pam agrees.
And so through a combination of therapy,
meditation and Yoga,
she finds her piece and she
understands herself far better.
And what she says at the end of our piece
is that the hard work of her twenties
has paid off for her and has laid the
groundwork for what she thinks will be a
much more positive, much,
much more energizing.
30 so she's looking forward to taking
advantage of the foundation she's laid.
And what she really wants to do is
help others who suffer like her.
She became a licensed yoga instructor.
She's going through other training.
And what she intends to do is to pay it
forward because she knows how long and
how hard her path was and she
wants to be able to help others.
So step one is being healthy and
you'll see when you read the book,
there's a set, the second piece in
the book is called sliding doors.
It's about a young man in college who
falls off a balcony and has serious trauma
and has to relearn. His
gait, has to relearn. So many
things we take for granted.
And so he's also looking back at his
life and the sliding doors because it was
going this way and then it went
that way. And so, you know,
all of a sudden he sees his life very
differently and he has the same idea which
is get healthy and then
bit pay this forward.
And all the people in his life who have
helped him, which is quite a large team,
feel that,
uh,
there's now new meaning in their life
as they realize sort of what you,
what you can do for others and also the
fight that people have to have in them.
So, uh, healthy is job one.
Um, but the second one,
which I saw some hands raise
on is about managing rejection.
And for these 20 somethings,
uh, you know, they grew up,
like many of them grew up in families
where they're told they can do everything.
The world's your oyster.
You know,
we tried to groom them for the most
possible successful outcomes ever.
We tried to make sure that they weren't
experienced too much failure of any
failure. We tried to make
their life just smooth as silk.
And of course,
that's not the way the world is.
And so I'm talking to a journalist,
his name is Sam Tabachnick. He works.
He worked for the Washington Post. He was
a contractor and a list. Very happy one.
Uh, they told him, well,
probably when the contract runs out
we'll be able to get you signed on as an
employee. But as you can imagine,
it did not happen. And uh,
so now he's faced with trying to
figure out what he's going to do next.
And you probably know that journalism is
not the easiest places to land another
job,
you know.
And so he sent email after
email and has coffee.
He talks about how many cups of coffee
he has to try to network to Atlanta,
his next job and all.
He feels his rejection facing him.
And he writes this, he says, frankly,
I just wasn't used to this kind
of repeated rejection growing up.
I might get rejected from
the travel soccer team,
but there was always another team to join.
I went to schools where
the teachers nurtured us.
Pretty much everyone got A's and B's.
There wasn't a need
for a 10 of tough love.
So the question is what to do next?
Because he wasn't finding a job.
He needed both money and purpose in
his life. So he became a Lyft driver.
This was not anything he ever imagined.
Uh,
he doesn't actually love driving cause
he finds a traffic to be very burdensome.
But what he discovered was that
when he was driving people,
he loved talking to them and he lived
almost interviewing them to see what was
going on with them, what they
were about. And in that way,
it confirmed for him the
journalism and reporting.
And it is really what he's about.
And so he continued to be a Lyft driver
until he found his job in journalism at
another job for a smaller paper.
Uh, as I ended up being, you know,
he worked his way through it. But
when the world tells, you know,
it's about not expecting the
rejection you're about to feel.
And I feel that was a theme that made
it through so many pieces in this book,
how to manage rejection,
the surprise of it all,
how to pick yourself up and
just keep on going forward.
So in terms of, uh, the,
the, the, the steps that,
the challenges that these contributors
had to conquer to get to a good place.
One was emotional and physical health.
Another one was understanding
and experiencing rejection
and being able to make
your way through it. Um,
but there's a third one,
which I think both the
parents and the kid share,
and that's called the
burden of expectations.
We expect so much from them and they
expect so much from themselves too.
And when you live under
these high expectations,
there's almost the only one place to go.
Uh,
and so I'm going to read
you another piece that I,
at the beginning of another piece.
So back to my asking people, uh,
what is a song, a poem, a book,
something that resonates with you and a
piece called a clash of perception and
reality.
Gabriele rams starts the following.
He says there's a delightfully smoked
scene in season four of the office where
Ryan Howard has been promoted to the
corporate office in New York City.
Ryan's climb up the ladder. It means
he will supervise his former boss,
Michael Scott,
clearly pleased with his progress.
Ryan's looks into the camera and says,
people keep calling me a wunderkind. I
don't even know what that means. I mean,
I know what it means.
It means I'm very successful at your age,
so it makes sense. And uh,
and then Gabrielle says,
I thought I was just like,
Ryan's skipping a dozen
steps on my way up.
I crave the satisfaction of
being considered a wunderkind.
He goes to work for a political newspaper,
he's super excited and he gets to
be in on the issues of the day.
He gets to me senators,
he gets to have all these super
cool conversation to things.
But then he realizes that she was
having dinner with his father who was a
journalist. So what are you really doing
where you know, we'll kind of work.
Are you doing,
where do you feel you're adding value?
The more he sorta of peels back the
layers, the more deflated he feels,
the less he likes the newspaper.
And he realizes this isn't
really a job for him.
It's not even a career track for him
and he is now disengaged from that.
He's going to go to a public policy
program in the fall and he hopes to enter
into a career of politics. It comes
from a very good place. He says,
I want to give more to the world.
Then I had a little more to the world
than I take back and so it's all good.
But his expectation of
being the Wunderkind,
that kid who would be able
to exceed all expectations,
that's a hard one to manage.
It's a hard one as parents,
when you place that on your kids,
and it's a hard one for kids who had their
own expectations that are quite large
and I think it doesn't always come
from a bad place in the parents.
We know that we know our kids and we
think know we want the best for them,
but it ends up being in a bad place
because it ends up putting pressure that
they already feel upon themselves anyway.
So when you decide to
go do fill in the blank,
what will you hope to get out of it?
If it turns out to be a path
that's not meaningful for you,
how will you know what's, uh,
a milestone, a measurement,
something that you hope to get out of it.
That's what's the marker that you hope
to see. And if you don't see that,
you know,
what would you do?
I think the problem is when we start to
place our answers on them and they're
not their answers. But, um,
I think it's tricky and maybe we have
some young 20 somethings maybe in this
room. Does anybody want to
offer any thoughts as to what,
what we could do, the older generation to
be a little more effective on this one?
Uh, I'm probably actually not even old
enough for this book to apply because I'm
only 19.
Um,
but I think one of the things that
a parent should do is probably,
um,
let their kid have other role models
other than like just parents and relatives
and stuff like that.
Because that's like a really good way
for the kid to be very isolated and have
like,
just,
they want to live the expectations that
their parents have for them. Right.
So other role models and really allowing
their kids to find other ways to get
their guidance. Yeah, exactly.
That's a great suggestion.
So the other part about that is why
don't you have this burden of expectation
and you'd go ahead and you decide
you're going to try to go live up to it.
What do you do?
And so they're contributors in this
book do a series of what I call
experimentation and wandering as
they try to find their way. Uh,
there is a piece by Carla Moody called
a series of new beginnings and she just,
she describes graduating college,
having no money,
having to get a job as a volunteer,
uh,
living with her aunt so she
can basically have free living.
And during lunchtime when people
might be able to do something,
she just wanders the street
walking because walking is
free and she loves water.
She's a Pisces,
she says.
So she looks at water fountains and she
entertains herself in the cheapest free
way possible. And from there she
ends up names. She just had, okay,
I need some money. She gets
a nanny job. From there.
She goes to work for Groupon
from their digital media.
She just wanders from one job to the next,
then she leaves Chicago and she goes to
Colorado. Um, and the last I spoke to her,
she's, you know, she said
every step along the way,
she learns something about what she
likes and what she doesn't and she now
understands. And this next job
she thinks she'll last longer.
And do you think she'll have a little
longer road on it but a wandering and
experimentation is the process.
And two things about that.
One is that I think if we were to repair
our high school kids and our college
kids for this is a trajectory that many
golf go through versus thinking they're
going to have a straight shot.
I think that would be helpful.
And I think if we ourselves as parents
prepare ourselves for this trajectory
that's windy and has starts and stops,
then that's helpful too because we placed
less demands on them and we place less
anxiety in ourselves,
which just ends up meeting and everybody
feels the anxiety that we feel.
So that's, that's an example, but
I'm on the experimentation piece. Uh,
I want to tell a story. There's a sudden
it was really funny. So as you know,
I asked,
you know,
give me something that I
source of something that means
something to you, a poem,
a song book.
And so I talked to this
man named Aaron Schoenfeld,
who I've never met and he
says to me, Oh, that's easy.
I love chem moves,
interpretation of Sisyphus.
Wow. Ken Mus interpretation
assists this. So it turns out,
let me give you a little background on,
on Aaron. He went to go work at city year.
He graduated college.
He thought it'd be a basketball player,
but his basketball career
wasn't as long as he thought.
So he studied anthropology and
he's all about giving back.
And he ended up joining city
year and going to Tulsa to teach.
Now he always high
expectations of what happened.
We went to Tulsa to go teach
high schoolers, but he said, um,
here's what he found. So he starts
off and he says, uh, that, um,
I spend most of my day mentoring and
tutoring students who are struggling with
attendance,
behavior and classwork.
I pull students out of class to
give them individualized support.
I met biweekly with students to discuss
behavior and attendance goals for the
week.
My services spelled feudal.
I could feel my activist spirit dwindling.
And so then what happens?
He, um, he realized, he
remembers, he discovers, he says,
I found out that it's tough to tell
students to do their homework when their
reason for not completing the assignment
was that they have no time in between
work.
They have no time in between working
to support their families and being the
primary caregiver to their young siblings.
So he was serving a very
impoverished, um, uh,
disenfranchised community and education
in the classic sense of what he was
trying to teach them was just not on.
It was not possible.
And so then he remembered Camou and you,
you know,
the mythicism business,
the boulder that you're trying to push
up and then it ends up coming down.
And so in the myth and in his interpret
and Campbell's interpretation,
the meaning is in the struggle to continue
pushing up and he says to fight the
nihilistic tendencies and woe is
futile and you have to find meaning.
And the in the every day grind of doing
the job and moving things forward and
the challenge of it all versus
the outcome of it all. And so, uh,
he says,
come and can't move.
The most important thing is that we
continue to believe in the world and in
ourselves. And in the struggle there was
meaning. So he completely reframes his,
his job and he alters his methods.
I had changed to more practical approach
hoping to meet students closer to where
they were instead of
where I wanted them to be.
And he describes what he does and he says,
all of a sudden the students
were improving their
attendance, their behavior,
their skills, and he says,
all was not exhausted.
My boulder awaiting me every morning,
but he was okay with it.
That was the challenge and
the value was in that push.
And so I think that experimentation is
just part of the process and that I'm
just like Wah Wah with Aaron Schoenfeld
and with Carla Moody, you know,
you have to,
you have to understand and expect the
fact that it's going to be sort of a fits
and starts and a lot of
learning along the way. So, um,
the last thing I want to
talk about is affirmation.
So you go through all this process,
you deal with rejection,
you're going to hell and
it's not sequential, right?
But you deal with rejection.
You've got yourself relatively in a
healthy place. You, uh, you know, you,
you manage your expectations and
or your family's expectations.
You're figuring out what you want to do.
But at the end game is that you can affirm
what you're doing and you as the one
of the contributors
says how to love myself,
that you really affirm what you're about
and then it has meaning to you and that
you can feel positive and go forward
with this, whatever your mission is.
So I asked her Steinberg as a comedian
and she's 28 years old and she is used to
being, when she gets on stage,
sometimes it's a friendly audience,
sometimes that's not a friendly audience.
You work hard to even get on stage.
She was on a Sitcom series
for a while that got canceled.
She just dealt with a series of
rejections that makes it hard for her to
continue to move forward. And yet there
was nothing else she wants to do in life,
but comedy and entertainment.
So she goes into therapy to sort of
work your way through depression.
And I'm going to read
you the story that she,
that her therapist tells her and I want
to take from you guys and whether this
would be comforting to you.
Um, I think is curious.
One day my therapist spent our entire
session telling me this long story about a
movie called Queen of the Nile,
which I had never seen.
It's about a missionary who goes
to Africa. Somehow the mission,
but missionary and a man end up on a
small boat and they sail for safety.
They both die on the boat after
a series of terrible events.
And right before the end of the movie,
the camera zooms out and reveals that
they were only a couple of feed from
safety. My therapist told me
that woman was me. Okay, so stop.
First of all,
would that make you feel better?
Hands up if it makes you feel better
to know that you're only a couple,
that the shoreline was right
there next to you. It's,
it's hard for me to imagine. Okay.
But here's what she says now I,
she said I was feeling desperate.
She said,
now I think go to a therapist
to her or him recap on movie,
but somehow it low as I was and feeling
assessment and I was hearing the story
brought me a glimmer of hope.
My take,
when you are in a moment
that is difficult and gloomy,
sometimes it helps to hear someone else
say you are so close and you can't even
see it.
So for her,
that story emboldened her and she felt
like there is hope that shoreline's right
next to her. And she kept on and she, uh,
she's actually doing very well. She's, uh,
she's on a series of shows and
comedy is going on and, but she,
she uses that as a
moment and she realized,
she asked it really just affirm herself
and remind herself does she is good. Her,
her skills are good. She can get there
if she wants to. Okay. Thank you so much.
Okay.